foreign
let's go to Kate in Stamford Connecticut
what is up Kate
hi good morning thanks for taking how we
doing
I'm very low how are you I'm good I'm
good what's up how can we help
okay
um in the last couple of months it has
come to life that there's been some
pretty significant financial infidelity
um for my husband who got involved in
day trading and has subsequently lost
about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars whoa um I know
um it's a giant pill to swallow and one
that I'm just honestly still like in
shock about wow I just I still can't
believe it I just can't believe it
um so this is a combination of about 105
000 in personal loans and about 42-ish
in credit card debts
um all of this was like within the last
you know maybe six seven months it
happened very quickly and honestly it's
all just come out now
um and so my concern is that the minimum
amount for all of this debt combined is
about 4 800 a month which is a that's
the minimum and my question to you is
what do you think about me taking out a
HELOC loan
um which hopefully would be able to pay
off all of this debt and then it's like
a more manageable monthly payment for me
you know because quite frankly we've got
two small kids there's 48 hundred
dollars a month in minimum payments is
it's crippling I don't even know how we
how do you do this for the rest of time
you know because if you're only paying
the minimum that's what we're looking at
oh gosh I can hear it on you oh my gosh
one I'm sorry I'm so sorry
um thank you thank you I want to First
Norm
what's going on inside of you
you are right to be
maniacally angry and you are right to be
stunned and in shock and grieving and
upset and scared and anxious all of
those things are right okay I just don't
want you to feel like you're going crazy
you probably are gonna feel like you're
going crazy but not because your
feelings are wrong okay
um I would be having all of those things
too what is your what is your entire
homes uh what is your take-home income
as a family
um
together we're at 250 000 annually okay
um I'll let Rachel hop in here here's
what I want to tell you
do not make a mess
even Messier
okay okay I know you can't breathe right
now your breath will come back to you
you'll have a big salary you've got a
huge huge mess on your hands yeah what
often happens is let's take regular
infidelity okay somebody you find out
somebody you love has cheated on you
romantically yeah there's this I want to
fix it I want to I want to solve all
this right this second so that we can
get back to quote unquote the way things
were
sure and what you want to do is you are
hurting so bad right now you want you've
got this magic HELOC that you want to
solve it all and you want to go do that
and take it out and just get back to the
way things were and then we'll we'll
figure it out later in a more manageable
way yeah the best way forward is you for
you to realize your husband to realize
what y'all knew before is now over
you're living in relationship 2.0
right and you've got to rebuild what
this thing's gonna look like together
and I think personally
what led your husband down this path is
something he's going to have to heal
from personally and you're all gonna
have to heal relationally and a quick
Band-Aid fix over this or just moving
debt from one arm to the other does not
solve that it kicks the can down the
road y'all gotta deal with this I'd love
to see him go get a second job a third
job and make this like crank this sucker
out on behalf of his family
and make this thing happen but
just trying to jump in and solve it and
fix his problem is is not the best thing
for your marriage for your financial
security for your kids long term
yeah Kate um not to make light of the
situation but one of my favorite quotes
from Warren Buffett which we used a lot
during the covid pandemic was people
make the worst decisions with money when
they're drunk or when they're afraid
and you are that second and so the the
fear that I hear from you which I get I
have three little kids and if that bomb
was dropped on me
um yeah you can't breathe you can't I
mean the the fear of knowing how how are
we gonna pay our bills how am I going to
get food on the table I feel
um this complete Whiplash in a marriage
sense from my husband the secrets that I
had no clues you're dealing with that on
one side and then the Tactical nuts and
bolts of being a mom with kids and
trying to figure out how am I going to
do this so I yeah I'm so sorry I I I I
hurt so much for you
um but I don't want you to make a bad
financial decision because you're in
fear and so what John was saying is so
right just take a breath okay and that
will come easier and easier with time
but don't getting a HELOC it moves the
problem from one to the other and yes it
can feel like okay the payments may be a
little bit different but that keeps you
guys in this mess and in this memory
longer and longer and longer and so in a
in a dream world you and your husband
sit down Kate together and you say okay
we make 250 000 you bring home probably
around fifteen thousand dollars a month
after taxes and say now we have this new
five thousand dollar payment so here's
what we can afford in our budget to pay
as is and I don't know what that looks
like for you guys we don't have time to
unpack every number of your budget but
say you have two three three thousand
dollars left at the end of your budget
in general right and then you're like
okay we gotta make up whatever the
difference is is it another two thousand
you got to make up uh and then I want
you to add on more to that because like
you were saying just paying the minimum
payment you're gonna be paying interest
and all this stuff it just keeps going
and going and so how can you attack it
and so I want you guys to run numbers
together or get a spreadsheet out get a
calculator out and just say Okay
scenario one you take an extra job and
you're going to make x amount per month
here's how quickly timeline wise we can
pay this debt off we can pay it off in
three years and two months if you take
two jobs and you work four nights a week
five nights a week we can pay it off in
two years and eight months and run
scenarios Kate okay sit there with a
yellow pad because what's going to
happen is uh and John says this all the
time facts are your friends when you
start to see numbers not just fear in
your head and not having a plan but when
you actually see numbers on a sheet of
paper that logic is going to help you
navigate the best decision and
um and man you you guys have a hard
three to four years ahead of you Kate
you do and and that is the unfortunate
part of marriage that when you are in a
unified relationship
it is now your debt even though it was
his decision that he went down this road
and so I would the anger is real and
Justified all of it um so I don't want
you to shy away from those things
because that is very real and that's
going to be part of your healing process
towards him Kate I wish you could feel
this I can feel the anger on Rachel
okay for you
but I'm like
what what was the thing right is it is
it an addict is there an addiction there
that he's like I think I could do it
it's almost a gambling feeling of this
day trading is it that he wanted
something else to be this I mean I've
like looked at every scenario and this
this can only be yeah
um it's day trading addiction it's not
necessarily gambling like at the casino
in my mind it's the same thing like it
is it comes from the same place
did you um not that this matters did you
find out on your own or did he come and
tell you
um to be honest with you I just had this
feeling something wasn't right and I
just looked at him I said tell me right
now what's happening and he just broke
down and I he only told me a little bit
at the time it wasn't that bad and then
a little bit more a little bit more and
then honestly just in the last few weeks
did the extent of this come out so I'm
in a deer in headlights right now I mean
he's not day trading anymore and um I
have direct deposit his paycheck comes
right to me so there is no more money
too yeah but I mean now I'm left with
having to carry this burden and make the
decisions who do I pay this month who do
I not and it I'm I don't want you to
dealing with this can't do it alone
can't do it alone you bring him and get
and if you guys have a good pastor a
good therapist a good counselor in the
area yes do that Kate and hold on the
line we're going to give you guys
um Financial Peace University and it's
not going to be the the Silver Bullet in
this situation but I I hope at least
getting on the same page
and that you guys have the same shared
goal and same vision it's going to be
really important so Austin will pick up
and give that to you guys for a year but
I'm so sorry Kate I'm so sorry I'm sick
to my stomach don't do anything for six
six months
just hang in there